dit que monsieur benalla elle n'avait
aucune mission de police
est ce que vous pourriez nous dire
comment se fait-il que s'il n'était pas
en charge de l'insécurité née du
président de la république
comment se fait-il qu'il est désiré
d'observer la mouvance des des black
blocks et quel était son intérêt dans
cette démarche est deuxièmement à quel
titre monsieur benalla à tulle
at il eu droit un appartement au quai
branly en juillet un passeport
diplomatique surtout que depuis le 4 mai
il n'était chargé que de l'organisation
des événements à l'intérieur de l'elysée
et et des déplacements privés du
président par ailleurs me semble t'il
qu'aucun chargé de mission de l'elysée
et ne bénéficient de tels avantages
je ne sais pas si monsieur le président
a reçu déjà les documents qui
m'interpelle
est-ce que vous avez communiqué l'arrêté
portant lançant la sanction ainsi que la
date de sa notification à monsieur
benalla avec épreuves de la notification
ces faits madame peut-être que je hais
les modalités de la suppression du
traitement durant quinze jours
merci madame benbassa est plus commode
que c'est que je prenne aussi la
question de monsieur coulombe a qui suit
je voudrais vous poser une question sur
le recrutement de le supprimer
vous avez dit que vous l'aviez recruter
formellement c'est vrai mais est-ce que
premier aspect est ce que c'est vous qui
avait sélectionné la personne ou est ce
que vous l'avez trouvée et d'autre part
qu'elle était là est-ce que ce poste tel
dans la définition vous en avez donné
existait déjà dans d'autres cabinet
précédent
enfin et c'est parce que si on regarde
bien et je m'en tiendrai là si on
regarde bien le seul point qui
paraîtrait quand même nécessaire dans
son travail pour vous c'est les missions
préparatoires house avait dit lisa
prophète il est pour aller alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils aident reste du temps
bien merci monsieur que l'on bat
monsieur pilet ce président alors deux
questions brèves qui devrait susciter
d'ailleurs des réponses très brève tous
les collaborateurs de l'elysée dont
évidemment monsieur benalla ont-ils
régulariser leur situation au regard des
obligations faites par la loi sur la
transparence de la vie publique en
déposant enfin auprès de la haute
autorité leur déclaration de patrimoine
et leurs déclarations d'intérêts pour
qu'elles nous soient communiqués
deuxième question quand avez vous appris
la demande faite par monsieur bénin
auprès du cnaps
c'est à dire du centre national des
activités privées de sécurité tendant à
obtenir l'habilitation à diriger une
entreprise privée de sécurité à
méditation qu'il a d'ailleurs obtenu
monsieur le chef de cabinet écoutez
concernant la question de madame la
sénatrice sûrs sur l'intérêt allège
pense avoir
répandu en tant que chef d'orchestre sur
les déplacements du président de la
république nous avons à connaître en
lien avec les préfets les considérations
d'ordre public
sans évidemment nous immiscer dans le
commandement des forces de police ils
étaient à mon sens donc pas totalement
inutile qu'on puisse qu'il puisse
participer en tant qu'observateur moi il
m'est arrivé dans ma carrière plus
jeunes sous préfet d'être observateur
à ce titre là je crois que beaucoup de
personnes le font sur l'appartement
je vous ai dit je crois fortement
quelles étaient ses suggestions dans le
cadre de son emploi ses horaires le
nombre de déplacements
le directeur de cabinet pas moi puisque
c'est lui qui gère le parc de logements
a décidé de lui attribuer ce logement il
ya beaucoup de choses fausses d'ailleurs
qui ont été dites sur ce logement
notamment quant à qantas à sa taille
ce logement il a été attribué dans un
cadre juridique qui est connue qui est
celui d'un logement pour nécessité de
de service il ne l'a d'ailleurs jamais
occupé et contrairement à ce que j'ai
dit à ce qui a été dit il n'a jamais été
occupé et contrairement à ce qui était
dit ne fais pas 300 m² il fait 70 m² et
cette situation me semble tout à fait
tout à fait légal sur la question de
monsieur passeport diplomatique et il se
trouve que les agents de la chefferie de
cabinet ont un passeport diplomatique
nous avons la possibilité de faire des
missions préparatoires ou d'accompagner
le président dans des déplacements
internationaux et donc nous avons un
passeport diplomatique
alors je crois que ça a été le cas de
tous les membres des chaufferies de
cabinet précédente également enfin à ma
connaissance monsieur collants bas sur
les conditions de recrutement
lorsque je suis arrivé à l'elysée le 19
mai monsieur benalla qui faisait partie
de l'équipe de campagne était était
présent je souhaitais constituer une
équipe avec beaucoup d'humilité
tiens à le dire il est venu ne réclamant
rien d'ailleurs il est venu se présenter
à moi j'ai observé ces grandes qualités
en matière d'organisation des
déplacements c'est connaissance
également en matière de coordination et
de sécurité et j'ai donc
proposé au directeur de cabinet de le
recruter et c'est lui évidemment dans
son rôle de gestionnaire des ressources
humaines qui l'a recruté par par contrat
comme comme vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur concernant les obligations de
déclaration à la haute autorité
il a été demandé à tous les chargés de
mission de le faire je ne puis pas vous
dire parce que là aussi je suis pas
secrétaire général ou directeur de
cabinet si ces obligations sont à
l'heure actuelle totalement rempli mais
on vous y répondra si vous en êtes
d'accord par de la part de là cet
échange mais en tous les cas la demande
a été faite à chacun d'eux dès le
lendemain de la question posée ici même
je crois ce président alors la question
du taps arrive en agrément comme et je
n'ai pas été responsables de sociétés de
sécurité c'est ça il t'a fait je n'ai
pas été informé de cette demande qui a
été faite par monsieur benalla qu'il a
fait a à titre personnel et sans passer
par la hiérarchie ça me semble pas
totalement étonnant c'est pas parce que
vous êtes habilité à diriger une société
de sécurité privée que vous la dirigez
merci monsieur nov
la parole est à monsieur quoi ça sert
messieurs et mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à quoi ça sert pour quelqu'un
qui est à l'elysée de solliciter
l'autorisation de diriger une société
de sécurité privées surtout pour
quelqu'un qui ne s'occupe ni de sécurité
ni de police rappelons le